and goods can see you oh it's great to
see you I'm I'm nervous and anticipating
disappointment that we won't get to meet
in Thunder Bay in September no word yet
but no I don't I I also don't think that
it's going to be because the problem
with Thunder Bay too is that it's far
away from everybody and so it means that
in order for them to even make it happen
they probably will need people to to
travel and so I don't yeah I don't see
it I don't see it's it's frustrating but
yeah yeah and what a year you've had I'd
saw your comments of you know Easter
twenty twenty nineteen flood 2020
pandemic yes local not in global flood
[Laughter]
and and I just watched this morning I
just watched your Donkey Kong video and
I thought it was it was tremendous
it was tremendous Jonathan I don't I
when I think when people first told me
about you and I watched some of your
first videos I'm like what is this guy
talking about
but you've you've seriously colonized
parts of me that I can't talk to people
and some of your some of your ideas just
haven't gotten so deep in my head that
so I owe you a tremendous debt of
gratitude for everything that I've that
I've that I've learned from you and so I
I just want to say that well thank you
that that really the donkey kong thing
it was really just because things have
gotten so grim you know in the past few
months and and understandably so but I
just felt like I just needed to do
something that was extremely light and
extremely that was showing the pattern
but it was didn't have that many
ramifications and so people have been
asking me to make a video game video
game symbolism for years and I've always
refused because there is something about
video games that I our video game
culture which I
I'm not super productive but I don't
have anything against video games like I
played video games once in a while too
um but anyway so I finally gave in and
I'm like okay I'm gonna make something
just fun and light and you know anyways
well I I thought I I really enjoyed it
cuz I'm old enough to remember you know
when you had to go to an arcade or with
the quarters yeah yeah yeah I pumped a
lot of quarters and machines at certain
times in my life what what does what is
your life looking like now for you I
know you spending a lot of time working
on your stuff making videos I mean cuz
your life I mean what do I wanted to
talk to you today is kind of a you know
go back over the last few years I mean
your life got turned upside down
definitely no definitely and you know
last year was probably one of the most
intense years I guess in my life you
know I've had pretty intense year that
last year was really intense also
because I had all planned to do a lot of
traveling and I did but I was also
dealing with the flood and all of this
and actually right now I feel like the
lack of traveling is actually feels kind
of nice I'm realizing that it's it
actually feels kind of nice to you know
just like everybody there's something
about this pandemic which there are a
lot of negative aspects to it for sure
but there's a positive aspect in the
sense that it's forcing everybody to
stop and I think that it's acting almost
like a little Sabbath or like a little
Jubilee and so it's forcing people to
stop and so it can it can be positive
because you have to kind of take some
distance and see what's going on you
also end up spending you know where I
spend way more time with my kids when
we're talking to my family and I'm
loving that the heart of it I just love
it um so I hope we can take some of that
into into the net like if when it starts
so when it starts again I hope we can
take some of that into the next
iteration of our society
you know they shut down the stores here
on Sundays
all the story so all the all the grocery
stores are all all the grocery stores
are closed on Sundays yeah and it's like
and and they did it for purely secular
reasons yeah yeah but I've talked to a
few people just regular people that
aren't even necessarily Christians they
said oh we love that it's cool that the
stores are closed on Sundays because we
don't have the self-discipline yeah not
to go to the store on Sundays but if
it's closed then you don't go and then
you end up spending more time with your
family and he just happens and so I was
like interesting well I so I grew up in
Paterson New Jersey and these Jersey
blue laws as they were called
you know they lasted into the 60s and
70s when shopping malls were closed on
Sundays and this is the New York
metropolitan area where you know one of
the more secular places in the country
these laws endured on the East Coast and
that of course I grew up in the
Christian Reformed Church which was very
sabbatarian so even if things were open
you didn't go because that was your
community didn't do these things on
Sunday hmm and and unfortunately you
know in the 70s and 80s the Christian
Reformed Church sort of began to dismiss
these things and the theological
justification for that was these are
these are this is liberalism or this is
um you know this is uh this is legalism
that we're not swimming on Sunday or
playing ball on Sunday or you know in
our in our house we couldn't turn the TV
on until after the second service on
Sunday that was kind of the break but I
wonder if this was some latent thing
from my Jewish ancestors on my father's
side it was sundown on Sunday after that
you could it's kind of a weird mix but I
you know I think so I've been so my wife
is a schoolteacher and before she was a
public schoolteacher we were home
schoolers and so she kind of got cast
into creating what essentially is
homeschool material for her public
school students because she had all this
homeschool experience
and wanted very mod very much wanted her
students in her classroom to be able and
the families to do some of that most of
whom don't really necessarily have a lot
of interest in that because it's very
demanding of the parents but you know
watching the disruption happen in
people's lives people are I think we've
had enough months of this lockdown where
people and the emerging is going to be
slow where people are going to have
learned something and at least
aspirationally are going to say I want
to take some of these new learnings and
blessings into my future but we'll see
how long that lasts we'll see how long
that lasts but how about you how I mean
what's life like for a pastor in the
world where there's no church I guess
like where there's no a physical meeting
how's it been it's it's you know it is
important that this thing happened
during Lent and I emotionally just hit
me a lot harder than I thought it would
just losing the rhythm of being with the
people hmm and so then you know I do
these little videos now for church for
the members the three members of my
church that can actually figure out how
to get on YouTube and I had to I you
know I got a one of my elder said you
know you gonna have to you're gonna have
to cheer things up a little bit I'm
sorry little depressed myself but
especially when we then turned the page
into Easter and the Easter and because
Easter is of course a season it's not
just a day I did the day yeah until then
and and so then I sort of had to lean
into even though we couldn't meet and
Jubilee is what I think about all the
time because I walk here to church and I
do this stuff in the building the empty
building where we have not had services
since mid-march and I think the it's a
little non Protestant of me but you know
the sanctuary is getting a Sabbath rest
and it's getting a Jubilee in a
where it'll be put to work again soon
but it's fallow right now and there's
that's not altogether a bad thing
damn and you can see what like you can
see kind of what the purpose of these
little deaths are because you realize it
well we actually have to restart because
things have broken down now we have to
restart and so for people who are keen
it's actually an opportunity to fix a
bunch of stuff yeah right it's an
opportunity to start on the right foot
as we say to start on the in on the
right path but you can't it's hard to do
that unless there's a breakdown you know
when things are when the gears are
turning and the wheel the machine is
running it's really difficult to change
things because there's almost a logic
there's a pattern that's running its
course and you know it's very difficult
to stop it but when these kind of things
happen then you know if you're attentive
it's an opportunity to make some changes
you know and Jonathan one of the things
that I think I have to again continue to
credit you with is it was probably a gap
in my Protestantism and I think you know
Charles Taylor brings this out in in his
work a secular age Protestantism tends
definitely towards the instrumental
towards the ADEA Gentek towards the
driving you know part of part of what
happens in going from let's say
two-speed where you had the the holy
persons and then the laity to the one
speed when John Calvin wants to make all
of Geneva in a sense the the City of God
what are one of the things that you I
think have really helped me with is
showing again you have the center and
you have the periphery and in in God's
creation they both have their place and
and I was watched also this morning I
watched you know the little clip that
your people I think it's
it's absolutely perfect that it's your
people who are selecting the clips
because people sometimes hope all your
videos are so terribly long why don't
you just do clips I don't know what
clips are actually the good ones yeah
exactly I I do feel very fortunate
because I can see what people pick out
of the queue neighs and what people pick
out of the videos that they find
interesting and so I'm like okay yeah
interesting interesting well and I saw
your little two little clip on Lilith
and I just I'm a Protestant you know we
don't read those so let's talk about
that Lilith yeah and but but you've I
think shown very well kind of the place
in the created order for these different
elements that sort of get pushed out of
the way in the agenting Protestant mind
and and you know you've really helped me
with that well thanks I appreciate it
and how have you been you've been still
doing a videos every day is that because
I see once in a while but I are you
still still have the same rhythm I do
video six days a week
I'm the seventh you have to go to the
church channel for the video it's you
know it's become part of my rhythm and I
you know I often feel I often feel like
a bad youtuber cuz when i watch your
videos I think boy Jonathan knows what
he's doing and Jonathan's doing it the
right way and I and I but I just kind of
use it for what I use it for which is
I've found that it's a good way to
engage in conversations and to try out
ideas with a really far broader audience
than little Livingstone's most of whom
I'll say things and they look at me like
what are you talking about but I think
you're doing I think it's just too
styled I think you doing more like a Joe
Rogan type discussion you know this
constant discussion and it has a great
advantage like I sometimes now I I feel
like I'm kind of out of the discussion
like I'm kind of I've kind of moved out
of the discussion
just because I've been busy I've been
doing all these different things and so
I'm not following the flow whereas
you're right in there and seeing you're
still you're doing videos about you know
about the portal and like John for Vicki
and all the stuff that's going on and
it's actually been seeing that you're
doing videos that you're doing videos
about that kind of stuff
now I'm like I've contacted a few people
like I'm gonna do I want to do a
discussion go on that you know that
group the stoah that yeah do and Peter's
yeah so I'm gonna try to participate in
that site like you know I need to get
back into a conversation I can't just be
the guy talking or else I'm going to
start talking in circles so I really
appreciate this ongoing conversation I
need to actually need to be more part of
it but I have kind of pulled away a
little bit especially from the whole
dark web like intellectual dark web
thing I never completely identified with
that name from the beginning and and so
I've also since Jordan has kind of moved
out of it I've also moved I think I feel
like I pulled out more just because the
things they're talking about I don't I
don't think they I don't think a lot of
the people like the one signs I don't
think they really understand the stakes
of what interests me and so because of
that I just it's a feel like there's no
conversation to be had with John though
John BIRT Vicki I think he totally gets
it I think like I wish that I wish John
could talk to someone like the wine
science because I think that that he
could have a really good discussion with
them um but for me I just feel like the
stakes
I just don't they I'm not communicating
the stakes of what I've been talking
about in a way that for a certain type
of atheist is not it's not clicking like
they don't know what I'm talking about
like for was that like rationality rule
you kind of engage him I'm like I'm not
engaging that that person I mean I don't
I don't think I don't think he even
knows what I'm talking about
like I think that you would listen to my
videos and think it's just gibberish
non-stop gibberish that's probably true
but I I I'll tell you I mean we're all
sort of and I see this as just part of
the economy of the kingdom of God that
here in his body has many members and
the hey
in the ear and the eye and the nose are
not all the same and they and in fact
it's it's God's good God's good purpose
that they're not but I see I see the
tremendous impact of your work on on
people that I'm talking to and and what
you have done is I think in a deep way
really
and I think this you know this is I
think this is part of your mission and
the mission that you've intentionally
embraced to you you have really helped
to rewire people to see and understand
and engage at levels that very little in
modernity would afford them to both and
I appreciate you that that's I think
that's vitally important especially as
we are in a period where I mean these
things take a long time to work through
chronologically in history but we are
the intensification of the breaking down
of modernity this is I mean it's it's
happening quicker than we think and
something like a pandemic well it kind
of works on both ends of it but it
speeds up the process oh for sure and
it's it's opening up spaces that we
thought were impossible you know I was
talking to a friend of mine today it was
not at all the Christian come this
regular liberal you know North American
and he he sees and he's not he's not
even like conservative like he he's a
left-leaning but he says I never thought
that I would see the government reached
so much in my life he said I didn't
think it was possible I didn't think it
was possible for the for the government
to reach so deep in our private lives
and you said all of a sudden within a
few weeks you know it's it's we have
people denouncing their neighbors
calling the police
and you thought wow this is crazy how it
can things change so fast
yes break it it's accelerating and this
2020 election for you guys is going to
be another major marker it's it's not
gonna get any easier but look at look at
the pause that again the the pandemic
has given us Trump can't go out and you
know fill a fill a stadium with cheering
fans Biden can't go out and press the
flesh in a sense we have two people that
are probably gonna be running anyway you
know so I frankly look at I I look at
what a feeding frenzy 2016 was and I
just I mean 2020 would have been another
layer up but this pandemic is in that
aspect perhaps part of the grace of God
to say we're gonna put a blanket on this
sucker because you know the world
doesn't need the world doesn't need and
Canada doesn't need the United States
flying apart anytime soon yeah well
we'll see because it's not it's gonna
it's gonna ramp up near the election cuz
we're gonna get cuz the they're gonna
get desperate
the candidates are gonna get desperate
to try to get the attend because now
that like you said the attention is not
on the election at all but it's kind of
they're seething in the background and
it's motivating actually a lot of moves
in terms of media the way the media is
framing things is Frank it's a lot of it
is based on the upcoming election but
it's it's gonna ramp up we'll see I hope
it doesn't like I hear there's no
discussion like here it's all Justin
Trudeau globalism it's it's wild like
how much everybody just agrees with
what's going on here in Quebec I think
it's gonna be in Quebec I think French
Canadians have a weird they're kind of
sheet we're kind of like sheep you kind
of follow it all kind of all just follow
in one direction but there's also
there's also like a low-level resistance
and and I think I'm starting to see it
right now you know like everybody's like
yeah yeah shut down shut down but then
everybody's outside and you know and now
I even this weekend I saw a few
restaurants that were kind of we had
that the door open and they had dad
tables outside and I was like okay let's
everybody's kind of pushing everybody's
pushing and I think it's people are just
gonna start just doing their own thing
at some point it's gonna happen that's
mostly it's probably gonna happen more
like that than coming from a top-down
decree people are gonna say okay you
know what this is not it's we're just
tired and we're just gonna we just need
to see people yeah and that's what's
happening in California right now the
governor the governor had laid down well
these are the things and then some of
the counties sort of you know broke and
then the governor very quickly realized
he didn't really have the power and
didn't want to so he kind of readjusted
the criteria some more counties could be
in and it's it's you know they the the
there's a Spanish saying la carga say
hey Glen El Camino which is that the the
load adjusts itself on the road and
that's exactly what's that's exactly
what's happening right now
but you know I really wanted to talk to
you because I I wanted to talk to you
about what you and I have been doing
over the last two and a half years and
because you your channel started a
little ahead of mine and I think it fits
into I mean it's interesting now that we
have this pandemic that that's happening
now but before I you know I got my
undergrad degree in history and so I've
always sort of got a historical mindset
to me and so before too much history
goes by I at least wanted to do some
talking and documenting about you know
what I've what I call the Jordan at
least wave one of you know Jordans wave
in terms of you know in Canada it was
c16 in the United States
it was the Trump election you know c16
was sort of October 2016
of course Donald Trump was elected in
November 2016 and then of course Jordan
Jordan you know there's no way to
separate it from Jordan and now you're a
personal friend of his so I you know you
have to be more careful than I do but
you know what happened Jordan had been
talking about this stuff for a very long
time and that evidence is out on YouTube
and of course you you caught wind of him
early before he took his status rocket
ride and you know you could just send
him an email and he could respond to you
and oh well here's this artist who's
doing stuff and you develop a
relationship with him but that moment
that just like you said things what
caught my attention in this was that
Jordan in the Jordan Peterson wave
things happened I didn't anticipate
seeing yeah a conversations could be had
that I couldn't have before yep and I
you know I was I was fortunate enough
that the Protestant if a cat if
Calvinists can use that word to have
sort of been at the right time and
gathered around me additional
conversation partners and for me that's
been the real takeaway from this thing
but I wanted to talk to you about this
before this history gets too old behind
us and and start with some of because of
course you had already started building
a relationship with Jordan and then
whoosh and then of course you start a
YouTube channel and well you're an
artist and you you know we've talked
about your life before this now suddenly
you're an artist who also makes videos
and of course just been a flood and a
pandemic and all of that so so what um
now thinking back to three four years on
this what what comes to the
of your mental salience hierarchy I
think that one of the things where we're
seeing is as we watch kind of the
breakdown of the of the West let's say
could say it that way the breakdown of
what has held the West together and we
see the breakdown of Christianity
the surprising thing about a breakdown
is that it also affords opportunities
and I think that that's something that
the people who had wanted let's say
religion to go away didn't realize you
know as narratives break down there's
also a spaces that open and those open
spaces are the reason why all of a
sudden conversations that we didn't
think we're possible are happening you
know because there's more connect
there's more connectivity there's more
like lateral connectivity you could say
it that way and I think that so I think
that that it's it's actually a very
exciting time because there's a
possibility for there's really a
possibility for a flip and I think that
that's really what Jordan did is is he
flipped the discourse he turned it and
what he did I mean it was already kind
of preparing there were people who were
kind of talking about it and it's not
like he came out completely out of the
blue with his idea but there's something
about him about his personality about
the way that he was also kind of like a
father figure oh there's all these
things that kind of came together and
the fact also that he resisted he talks
about Jordan talked about this quite a
few times where he said he took it out
of the abstract and and and chose a
place right said this this thing here is
where I'm not going to move and that's
what the bill the c16 thing was and he's
often said that it was it was near
arbitrary in the sense that there other
things happened before that that we're
in the same vein and other things have
happened since but it's like he said
this one is the one I guess I'm gonna
stay no and like I'm stopping here
and so there's something about there's
something about that where he he kind of
flipped the discourse into in terms of
religion let's say cuz he did it in a
lot of things but in terms of religion
he he brought the he brings the end of
the the evolutionary thinking to its
inevitable conclusion and the inevitable
conclusion is you know that
that this is you know that thing that
you marginalized all this time this
religion thing you marginalized it well
if you if you're in the if you're in the
evolution mindset it has to participate
in the pattern and this is the same
thing with consciousness it's the whole
problem of consciousness - it's like
people just stood in consciousness and
were describing the world and then you
come to the end where it's like the last
thing to to analyze is the thing you've
been not talking about and then when it
turns back on itself then it creates
this weird flip and that's what I think
Jordan did a lot of the things that I
think were the most powerful things that
he talked about were the the things that
lead into the notion of of of attention
and relevance the relevance realization
that that now john has been kind of
taking up I think that that's the most
powerful thing that Jordan brought to
the to the floor in terms of in terms of
shattering the categories that people
have been using and forcing this the
scientific mind to think to see
differently and I think no one has
gotten over that yet like people are
still processing that and it's but in a
way it's the moment he's gone in a way
because now at least for now because
Jordan is has kind of he's vanished and
and the effect of Jordan vanishing has
been huge it's been huge in the sense
that like he I know that it's part of
why my views have gone down I know that
it's part of why the discussions have
slowed down why there's less of this
interconnect connectivity you know it's
as if without him there is no
intellectual dark web really yeah yeah
right there's just been Shapiro and the
Weinstein Weinstein's and and they can
kind of talk to each other but they they
don't there isn't this this problem
that's there this kind of weird thing
that we have to solve that Jordan was
kind of bringing to the table somehow
well I very like hello he put it because
he sort of brought they connected via
him
and without him right there the
Weinstein sort of go back to the things
they talked about and ben shapiro does
his stuff on politics and yep you know
and and of course why would Ben Shapiro
and and the wine Stein's
over why would these two talk hmm if
Jordan doesn't sort of connect them why
did very little few reasons yeah why did
you start doing youtubes I started
because of Jordan I mean I I we did that
video we did a video we did the two
videos one was called tradition and
things that don't fit and then the
metaphysics of Peppe and then what
happened is I got invited to do an event
with him in Toronto and so I I did that
event and he put that up and you put up
those other videos and so it was like I
had a few I appeared on his channel a
few times and people started writing me
and I started getting flooded with
emails of people saying can you
interpret this like this this symbolism
of this and symbolism that and I
realized okay well I can't I'm not gonna
answer all these emails so I have to I
kind of have to I guess I have to do
something and since it was it was a
happening on YouTube I figured then I'll
make youtube videos because really as
silly as that it's it's interesting to
me how you and your brother you know cuz
your brother's your you know with his
book I mean he's very much a part of
this story even though he's not on your
channel and and I also you know when
earlier we talked about the fact that
you've sort of taken a step back because
you know I wrestled with this as a
pastor you know yeah I put out a lot of
videos and I do a lot of conversation
but in some ways I think this is true of
John Verve a key to in some ways sort of
the space that a pastor holds is
different from the space that an icon
carver holds yeah because an icon Carver
in a sense in a sense I
would imagine and please correct me if
I'm wrong in a sense I would imagine
you're sort of an artistic monk I guess
sort of your vocation yeah and and a
youtube you know a YouTube celebrity I
remember you talking about your kid
describing you my father makes YouTube
video you tuber my dad's a youtuber
that's been reduced to that nice joke in
my in my family yeah and and again I
think here too in this way Jordans
absence sort of means the circuit isn't
running like it was it's not it's not
necessarily bad there's some positive
aspects to that you know there it's like
different waves and so right now what
I've been doing I would say in the past
since I guess it's it actually is since
Jordan kind of vanished
I've been consolidating the things that
have better that I've been given to me
you could say it that way
and so I've been focusing a lot more on
getting the conversation to to run
within the people that have been
following my videos and now we just
started a blog where people that are
that have been watching my videos for a
few years that are on this Facebook
group that discusses the symbolism and
have read in my brother's book now I've
kind of JP you met JP masu so he's
editing the blog and people can submit
articles that are doing symbolic
interpretation or they talk about
symbolism for the blog and so that has
been I put a lot of emphasis on that in
the past few months kind of getting that
started I don't think there's going to
be a massive public for it but I think
that it's going to be a good training
ground for a lot of people and it'll be
a resource for those who want to go
further into to symbolism and so that's
kind of been my that's been my focus in
the past few months has been to try to
to seek to make this into a team effort
so that it's not just me talking about
symbolism but that there's there's
you know a few dozen people that really
understand what I'm talking about and
can understand some facets of it that I
don't and can use the the lens of
symbolism to look at things that I don't
have the energy or the interest to look
at and so and so that's it's been that's
been exciting to put together and I'm
looking forward to - already the
articles that have been going up we've
been live for about two weeks or three
weeks maybe and the articles that have
been going up have been great just
wonderful really really good stuff so
you know it's I this this last weekend I
used you probably know the YouTube
channel like stories of old yeah it's
it's a movie interpretation channel a
Dutchman another Dutchman and you know
when I was working on when I was working
on he'd done a couple of videos is gonna
do a third one in this series about
story vs. reality and of course that
immediately caught my attention and you
know they did a video on story vs.
reality it's got a series he's got two
out and a third one is coming very very
interesting that as a preacher I just
kind of jumped on it right away
and because it sort of fit in I was I've
been working through first Peter in
during the Easter season and what was
what what you know one of the things
that and I think about this a lot
actually with your work where there's a
there's a there's an interesting tension
involved in both being the artist and
the explainer yeah because in a sense
your videos are about bringing up to
consciousness that which is already
forming and shaping and molding beneath
now there's a prophetic mode in that of
you know oh my people you are absorbing
you are absorbing the worship of bail
and you don't even know it and so allow
me to bring up to your conscious you
know that the part of you that is kind
just the formation that is happening
beneath the surface and of course for
all of us we have a certain we have the
pleasure of insight this the emotional
psychological pleasure of insight in
that process which i think is part of
the joy I have in watching you take an
arcade game and once you say it it's oh
gosh this is the most this is the most
obvious thing in the world I never you
know I never recognized how this ties
into the rest of creation but just in
the first few minutes it's like you know
what why was I too dumb to see but then
there's this other moment of realizing
that oh my I have been deeply formed and
the little conscious self of the me that
managing manages these things is in very
many ways weak helpless has been subject
to programming far beyond and now
Jonathan POJO comes up and makes me
think differently about masculine and
feminine right hand left hand center and
periphery but yet as an artist in a
sense you're both the the former as the
artist in some ways you're like the
magician who goes on YouTube and shows
the how the tricks work exactly it's the
only reason why you have to do that is
because there's there's been a lot of
really evil magicians in the past to
generate few generations you had a few
really bad Wizards that have been
distorting reality and and using one of
the problems that we've had in the past
few centuries is that a lot of
Christians took the science pill like
they just took it completely and they
went down the critical historical
scientific path and those that took up
the storytelling mode and who
intuitively understood the patterns were
those that really you just wanted to
destroy Christianity and so you have and
so all the people who are really good at
storytelling where though
that we're using these symbolic patterns
to undermine the Christian narrative and
Christians were too busy answering with
this or that like statue that are bold
that they found in the sand and in
Palestine you know and they they lost
the story and and you can see because
who are the Christians right now like
it's all it's all its es lewis' and Toki
right it's like that's our only that it
like that's our only two storytellers
it's it's those two in the whole 20th
century we've got those two whereas the
you know people those that want to have
been wanting to undermine have every
other story and so maybe not every other
story but a huge amount of this
storytelling and so it feels like one of
the things that I want to do is I want
to give back the power of storytelling
to the people who could do it because
the thing is that the the token story is
the is more powerful it's one of the
most powerful stories that were has been
told in the 20th century BarNone like
nope not even the Christian or not it's
it's one of the most influential stories
that has surfaced in the past few
hundred years and it's it it's because
it has totally infiltrated culture in a
way that people don't even realize it
all your video games have token behind
them all years a lot so much of your
science fiction all the world-building
that you see in science fiction that you
see in in in fantasy stories it's all
Toki he's the one who who gave you that
and so that's how powerful if you tell
the right story that's how powerful it
is
right the right story taking a story
let's say like a Disney story that
somewhat twisted like a Moana or
whatever there's enough of it to for it
to be true but there's enough of it for
it to be twisted but if you were able to
to to take it and just give it back in
its pristine form then it's gonna win
because it's truer and
that's what I thought I would say like
one of my main goals has been to give to
give back to to Christians or to people
who don't want to undermine everything
to give them back the pattern so that
they can use them because it's not
enough to interpret these movies this is
I mean this is really hopefully it's
just groundwork for people then to be
able to to tell better stories you know
it strikes me again as I was watching
like stories of old as I was watching
him basically deconstruct as I was
watching him deconstruct I just had the
sense that that that effort will always
fail and so that something was doing he
was saying reality is what like
meaningless and random well he's saying
well here so-so story well well he was
in a sense saying well here's the trick
of story you know the end and therefore
you selectively construct the bits and
that's how psychologically you create
story that's unlike reality of course I
okay tell me what reality is well he
doesn't say it out loud but the
assumption is what reality is just one
random chaotic purposeless event after
another
that's what reality is and so now we
have these stories and so I'm waiting on
his third episode where I suspect he
will make the move that the freedom from
religion people make every time they put
up a bull board in Sacramento which is
say I can bring the meaning myself and I
think yeah yeah I definitely have to
watch the video because that's that's
hilarious
it's so funny because let's think of a
very short story in terms of human in
terms of human interaction all your
actions are based on an end there's no
action that you make any every action in
the world is based on an end now whether
or not the end resolves itself one way
or the other that's a different story
because there are stories that don't end
well even in a even in a movie but the
the purpose is there so we always act
for ends there's there's no action
without an end so I it's just funny to
think it's like you know the end
well when I'm pouring a glass of juice
from the fridge I
so no the end like I that's why I'm
doing it or else I wouldn't do it if I
didn't know at the end was oh well and I
think I just I just finished a very
interesting conversation with Brett
shackled Brett is the author he's a
Roman Catholic from Regina Saskatchewan
who's the the the theologian for the
diocese and Regina and he wrote this
what to me was a tremendous book on
transubstantiation and where basically I
think in many ways he began helping
Protestants Lutheran's Calvinists and
Catholics understand each other by
showing some of the ways that Luther and
Calvin were trying to recapture Aquinas
and didn't understand what they were
doing it's a fascinating book and how
did I get at him well I ends these ends
because we're talking about conspiracy
theories yeah okay and again I think
some of your work on this has been
really tremendous and and has deeply
influenced me and you know Mary Coe
Cohan has been really helpful for me -
she's Roman Catholic she listens to all
of us and she does her own little
commentaries but you know how you lay
these things out and and so here like
stories of old I think is basically
going to say he's going to make the move
well this is such telling language we
don't really have purpose because this
is of course what Sam Harris says about
again when you're pouring the glass of
orange juice there's no such thing as
purpose it only looks like purpose you
know
and you experiences that as purpose so
what the Freedom From Religion
Foundation says is that while we can
enjoy the experience of purpose and we
can we can live as if there's purpose
but there really isn't any and it's like
oh you're talking about why are you
working so hard on this
yeah what why and and and in fact
because you can't you can't tell the
story that there is no purpose unless
you use all of the tools of purpose to
tell the story and in that sense the
tools themselves betray the purpose for
which they were given and no matter you
know no matter how much you use that
hammer to deconstruct
the hammer is more real than the pile of
rubble you leave on the floor that's
right yeah that every every move you use
to tell me that there's no purpose is
based on is you're using all your
purpose-driven mechanisms to tell me
that there's no purpose like what
exactly is your purpose and telling me
there's no purpose if you've got to have
one
you definitely have one it's a very dark
cynical purpose that you've got and
trying to do that and so you know when I
was you know so I first started you know
I made just be a pastor looks at Jordan
Peterson and then of course people
started coming to me which was an
unusual experience for me in in ministry
because they usually have people
avoiding me and so people start coming
to me and they start telling me and of
course we never we saw them quite know
what's really going on we just
experience things and make up reasons
that sort of seemed to fit maybe are 20%
right and and then I'm talking to all of
these people and realizing a good
percentage of the people I'm talking to
were depressed and then they tell me I
watched hours of Jordans video and I'm
not depressed anymore and what's more I
kind of think I want to go to church
yeah I don't know why and and then the
crazy thing especially as a Protestant
not necessarily making Protestants very
terribly happy I'll talk to you because
you're easier to find and talk to than
Jordan but what I really want to do is
be Orthodox edit and as a Protestant I
sit here and I think you'd better you
better count the cost of this endeavor
my friend because the
Orthodox don't just let anybody saunter
in on one Sunday and say I believe walk
down get baptized and now you're right
yeah yeah it usually takes a year before
they baptize you that's for sure
so so again I mean my my entire video
project at least the part that that
connects with Jordan has been to try to
figure out what he's doing and and you
know I'm not always so sure but none of
us always none of us ever know all that
we're doing but but sometimes I watch
Jordan and I think I wonder if he knows
all the levels he's working on because
we can see them by the effects yeah and
that's exactly why I don't want to do
little clips of me because we who are
even doing the work only know the
effects by watching what comes back to
us hmm yeah I mean I I agree I think I
think he's probably he might be more
aware than what you think though he's
actually I think he's quite aware he's
also aware he's even aware at the level
in which he speaks because I even one
time I had a conversation with them and
I won't say who I was criticizing but I
was I was kind of commenting on someone
a YouTube someone on YouTube and I said
you know I don't think he's very that
he's that smart that person and and
Jordan said yeah but he's a stand-in for
like the common person and he was like I
want that's where that's who I want to
talk to like I don't want to talk to
because a lot of people have criticized
Jordan because he his stuff isn't
formulated in in complicated technical
words and all of this and it it sounds
very everyday and it's because that's
what he wanted to do he really did want
to connect
to connect right to the people and talk
be able to speak at different levels but
if he's talking to Ian McGill Chris he's
able to read go up and talk about about
that stuff too but he doesn't feel he
doesn't feel like it has to prove to
people that he's smart you know and used
complicated words all the time to kind
of to kind of show people that he's
smart um and so I think that he he I
think he's more aware than we think
sometimes of of what he's trying to
accomplish and like trying to gather the
levels together to have this like weird
effect he probably also knows that that
that he was playing a kind of father a
dad figure as well like he's I'm sure he
he understood that but it's hard because
we again he doesn't it's hard to have
access to him and now you know be people
who you should be left alone that's
right you know when I it was so funny
because I you know I saw he was coming
through California and I okay you're
you're you're in Oregon and then you're
gonna be in Sacramento then you're gonna
be in the Bay Area then you give me in
Southern California son Rogan when he's
doing that I'm just kind of looking
between the lines and I'm thinking yo
dude a schedule like this as a pastor if
you were in my church I wouldn't
recommend it yeah I'd say that that's
that's there's a there's a lot that goes
into that in terms of the churn and the
people and and all of that you know and
and as you know I I shouldn't say I
didn't ask for it but I guess when I
made a video I asked for it so part of
what so so part of what I've done and
people sometimes ask me what I do and I
say well I'm a pastor I'm just sort of
pastoring in a different way right now
and so I you know with the discord
server and with the conversations a lot
of it is and that the meetups which we
can't do right now you know a lot of it
is you know to me to me the focus is on
the community that I leave behind me and
and the power of that community and
obviously I just I just passed her a
tiny little segment of this community I
think that's great III think in a way
with the kind of these discord
discussions and everyone and everything
I think that's probably the best thing
to do right now like I talked about the
idea of consolidating what's happened in
a way and trying to to now gather up you
know the the pieces of things that have
been transformed and tried to make them
more more solid more just more coherent
so I think that it's great like that if
you've got this discord discussion and
you've got people talking to each other
and everything kind of an extension of
the meetups because it's hard can't do
meet up with everybody but to have a
discord discord discussion is connect
create something of that you know okay I
know a discussion well and and to me the
you know I look for people's motivation
not just to so let's say have a little
conversation whether it's by text or
voice chat or even zoom but their desire
to to begin to build something and so it
was members of my local meetup who built
the bridges of meaning discord server
and and they've kind of they kind of
coalesced around a bunch of people that
I had zoom conversations with and posted
on the channel and it's it's sort of
built since there and and sort of that
sort of becomes an estuary for me if
people want to talk to me well even I
you need it's even hard for to get a
Rando slot right now because I only have
certain number each week and but I want
to keep them open because then you know
this is some of what you've taught me to
and and Jordan there's there's a real
value in and leaving a space for that
which I won't filter mmm-hmm into my
life and it can't be everything but you
can't have none hmm there needs to be a
space because then through that space
comes you know yeah surprise comes all
kinds of things that you hadn't thought
about things you hadn't considered for
sure yeah so so
well I guess two thoughts come to my
number one you know is there will gosh
is there gonna be a second wave and if
so what let me Jordan Scott we said you
know you had a couple tweets yesterday
and I thought yeah he's he's you know
this is this some of this pattern is
Jordan and you kind of see what's
publicity and what you know they're just
putting out to keep the social media
machine playing and then what comes out
now there there's some Jordan behind yes
and so it's possible he's working mostly
working on his book well exactly and and
so it's it's going to be very
interesting to me because he okay so we
had C 16 we had the election of trumps
at Trump and we had you know everything
that we've had in clown world we've had
Joker now we had a pandemic now we're
having a pandemic and so you know a big
part of that wave Jordans wave was also
I mean the man and the moment found each
other and and then I you know you're
right he mean he C 16 the more I think
about it was in so many ways exactly the
right inflection point to hit something
if you're gonna create a wave mm-hmm but
the world that the sequel and it'll be
interesting to see to what degree it is
a sequel the world that the sequel comes
into is a different oh yeah it's a
different world for me you know as a
pastor you know people come to me and
okay so you listen to Jordan and you got
red pill door bread pilled or any other
pill you want to conceive it as and you
want to remake your life and you want to
do things differently and you're gonna
listen to Jonathan Pozzo you're going to
need to there's going to need to be
patterns habits disciplines institutions
community if that shining moment of
Revelation that you experienced
is going to bear any fruit at all it's
going to have to and I really do I put
that comment on Twitter but your video
of the seeds I thought if if I had to
show people one someone who at least
knew something one video to say what
Jonathan POJO what I think his message
is boy that video was I thought well
there's the seed of the jaw of the
Jonathan POJO plant well I don't even
know what video is this the soils the
parable of the soils oh the soil yeah
the parable of the of the of Christ as
the sower yeah yeah that's right
that's right yeah oh yeah I I think so I
think you're right that that also
because it has the meta pattern inside
of it it has like it has a pattern as
the meta pattern and it's Christian yeah
yeah I I I don't I'm curious to see like
how I feel like this maybe I'm wrong but
I feel like there isn't gonna be like a
second wave I think there's gonna be
something else I mean I think Jordan
will have his place in discourse oh
you'll have his place in in the world
but I don't see his second book having
as big an effect and I don't see unless
there's another controversy unless
there's some controversy I don't I don't
see I don't see I see I think I'll say
something in that book you know at all
yeah he'll touch people maybe but I it
seems like there might be something else
like there might be another I don't know
what it's gonna be because you never
know what it is until it happens yeah I
think we just have to be ready to take
advantage of whatever flashpoint is
there which can create another level
where can bring people to the next level
or to create insight the right type of
insight that needs to to happen and
that's why I talked about consolidating
because if you consolidate the people
that you've been talking to then you
know it for example like let's say you
and myself
the reason why it's parked us let's say
is because we the soil was already
prepared it was stuff that we were
already thinking about or that that we
already had our something in our life is
prepared to kind of to take that and to
move on to move with it you know um and
so I think that maybe that's how I see
it now I think now is the time to plow
the soil or to - to get people ready
people who have already were already in
the discussion already thinking you were
already you know who have had some
insights - for the next for the next
moment where it's gonna jump again but I
don't know what that's gonna be I have
no idea yeah yeah I mean it could be
because anything can happen right now it
I mean people don't and when things
start to accelerate in these weird
chaotic moments it's there is no telling
what's gonna what's gonna happen because
if we if you had known if you could have
known that let's say I don't know when
maybe what's six years ago I would have
told you
Trump drags it pandemic and the Jordan
Peterson and you know people who were
hardcore atheists all of a sudden have
stopped being so aggressive when they
they still hate religion but they feel
like they can be as aggressive as they
were
you know even people like Sam Harris
isn't as cocky as he was anymore yeah
and I don't think maybe he wouldn't even
acknowledge it but it's that's what it
seems like yeah you know this this so
I've been reading Robert Putnam wrote
Bowling Alone and so Eric had Ross no he
had a JD Vance on his podcast and JD
Vance
have you read hillbilly elegy okay you
know who JD man says okay and and JD
Vance mentioned I mean it was it was
just something very interesting to me so
JD Vance writes about his grandmother he
grew up out in Appalachia and his
grandmother was you know she believed in
God didn't go to church because the
pastors were all you know hucksters and
grifters but she you know she believed
in God and she trusted that God would
make things right and so on and so forth
and and so of course for Vance that
caught his interest now he eventually
know if he's I think he's in a Roman
Catholic Church now I'm not sure I mean
every you know in terms of the big line
and and I think you get this writer than
most you know we're we're back to
sacraments mm-hmm and we're back to
icons and we're back to the imagination
that imagination that's in a trust what
I say that word we're we're back we're
you know I saw this I saw this coming
with Protestants that seeker movement
was sort of you know back to stripped
out churches whose smoke machines using
using proverbs to gain wisdom to get a
little bit of credibility to sneak in
the four spiritual laws and the sinner's
prayer and then I watched in the
response to that
everybody suddenly wanting well I want
one of these old church buildings with
with architectural features and I want
chanting and I we're gonna get a cantor
and these are these are Dutch Reformed
churches doing this and I'm watching
this thinking what's what's going on
there and so you're getting again and
you talked about this before I saw
anybody else talking about it kind of
this this inversion this return and you
know then I dreamed up Chesterton's the
last chapter before the conclusion of
the everlasting man he talks about you
know the seven deaths of Christianity
and and you talk about you know
basically Chesterton says Christianity
as many times died and then it keeps
coming around again and I've heard you
talk about this a number of times which
is it's a process it's it's the duck we
I could kind of color the double
inversions it's the so a good a good
example is that example that you said
where the church decides that in order
to reach out to the world it has to be
more like the world right it has to be
more like the people you're reaching
towards and so it keeps so it but in
order to do that it has to dilute itself
it has to dilute itself in order to
reach out you know and it's a form of
of kenosis you could see it that way if
you want to it's like an ending of
yourself to move out but at some point
there's a point where you reach a limit
where it's like if I go one step further
mm-hmm I'm not myself like I'm it's over
like there's nothing and so the church
the evangelical church is like oh we
could use advertising techniques we
could use you can use moviemaking
techniques we could have dance we can
have this got smoke machines we can have
rock bands and then you get to the end
where it's like okay
you're still not as good as a rock band
you're still not as good as a dance
troupe
you're still not as good as an
advertising firm but you've come all
this way and so now you're at the edge
and the only place to go is now it's
like well I actually forget where I've
forgotten where I've come from and so
there the move to remember is a normal
move it's like it just kind of happens
on its own I have to now remember what
where I came from it's almost it's even
there's even something in that in the
idea of transgression itself where you
can only be a rebel if there is
Authority and so rebellion ultimately
ends up reinstating authority
necessarily because the rebellion makes
no sense if authority breaks down right
and that's the whole idea of the clown
to where at the end it's like the clown
flips it back because it's it's like
when you've made fun of everything and
the whole world is a joke then the only
thing left to make fun of is the joke
itself you make fun of the joke and then
it turns back and you come back to the
king you know and people play that out
in their lives I've often noted that in
conservative Christian Reformed when
conservative Christian reform 'ti still
existed and still those in some rural
places it was the rebellious youth who
became the authoritarians when they were
they're older yeah and they were older
yeah and and you just watch I seen that
too I've seen that happen to teenagers
who were so rebellious and then they
become pastors and they're like that's
how they are like they're hardcore and
that even you see that people who
convert to Islam - you see that - a lot
of people convert to Islam are people
who are like completely out there and
then no and then I need something solid
like I want something solid now yeah
yeah and they become hardcore because
yeah is Lomb gives them those those
bright lines and the traditions and it
and it's all there
well I i I've peppered you enough
Jonathan and you've been you've been
gracious any anything you wanted to
bring into
this conversation we're like where'd you
feel your ad in terms because I've now
because you used to comment mostly what
Jordan was doing yeah and so he's been
gone for like you know four six eight
months even more and so what has been
your driving force like what has been
what has been the thing that keeps you
discussing right now well I've been had
Jordan sort of well when he when he went
on his book tour so I've been I read
Ross Douthat book on decadence and I
found that I found that really helpful
to try and get a sense of what's really
happened in the culture since the 70s
you know I watched The Joker moveme
movie and I felt like I was watching my
growing up and then I realized yeah he
filmed that in Newark New Jersey I was
watching my growing up years and and so
trying to get a Ross Douthat
Peter Thiel has had some interesting
ideas about lack of progress mm-hm and
and so I've been trying to get a handle
on and again increasingly lately
everything I think I'm looking for I
start finding in Chesterton and as a
Protestant who who is very dismissive of
Calvinists that can be unnerving in some
places because Chesterton made that
point in I think it was the second
chapter in his book entitled heretics
that this world can't find the good can
only sort of find the good in terms of
opposite of the negative mmm-hmm because
they can only see the negative and they
can't see the thing that the negative is
moving against it's their only think
seeing things in its shadow and and so
I've been doing a lot of thinking about
the last the last 60 years of history
the 60s to the 70s to the 80s to the 90s
and and then now and how okay everybody
everybody wants to be progressive what
what exactly are you progressing
towards oh yeah my goodness because then
I you know I I'll here I'll watch the
and I think the the pandemic has taken
some of the wind out of the progressive
this sales right now yeah hard to know
where that will actually go but okay so
what exactly is your tell us what
exactly what beyond the code the the the
heat death of the universe do you
actually want yeah and so that's and so
I've been you know I've been thinking a
lot about that and on one and also
continuing on my my god number one and
God number two because thinking and this
is where you know I wind up with a bunch
of Roman Catholics which again what do I
do with that with my Dutch Calvinism no
I'm not converting all you people that
have been cheering for that in the
comment section but what do we mean when
we use this word God and again your work
has been tremendously helpful for me to
and to understand that that in some
weird way God is everywhere and nowhere
and the whole earth is full of his glory
but the you know all of creation does
not exhaust him by any means and noting
in you know I've been it's been very
interesting watching television shows
like the good place and upload watching
humanity's crisis of confidence that
even if we had everything our way we are
finally a shallow cup that is too
shallow to actually contain the desires
that the universe that we desire and
that sort of backs me into CS Lewis's
argument for just from desire that deep
in our hearts we know we were made for
more
then even what our imaginations now cast
on screens with with zeros and ones that
we think we can make anything in the in
the virtual space and then we discover
no we we are we're bumping into our own
limitations again and so that to me then
leads back to the the nihilistic despair
of humanity that if if we are finally
the own there's no finally and there's
finally no agent above us or beyond us
then we are then we are locked in a
prison of our own despair mm-hmm and and
this to me just opens up you know
Christianity and what the whole story is
about yeah yeah that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense and so are you
seeing in the discussion that's
remaining let's say glimmers of that
because I saw you were kind of you were
kind of listening to the portal and you
were you know breaking down some of the
things they're talking about trying to
find some some moments that express more
let's say a desire for more like you
said
do you see cuz it I'm curious like what
is this the solution like what is the
solution that is for example like the
the on the on the portal like what is
the I was listening to one of the videos
we did where he was taught I don't
forget we was talking to and he was
talking about telling people that he
should have kids or something like if
you have kids then that will give you
meaning and everything and and I kept
there was something so fragmentary about
that type of thing where it's like it's
like yeah okay but you know I don't
think that that's enough I mean I don't
think that people will feel like that
that that's enough and also why like is
it just to follow some biological drive
to to to to reproduce and if so then
what what's all this other stuff like
what's this all this whole other thing
that's going on this whole civilization
thing this whole art thing this whole
what is that like what is going on you
know if we find meaning in the being in
you know reproducing the species because
we're programmed to do that
I don't I don't there's more don't you
worry obviously agree with me but yeah
look that's so he was talking to Ryan
holiday who Ryan holiday is doing
YouTube videos on stoicism and again if
when I was in when I was first learning
what who Stoics were if you had told me
that in 2020 there would be a stoicism
movement on YouTube yeah and you're
gonna talk to the Stowe I mean so you're
gonna talk to say anything to them yeah
and and the funny thing about stoicism
is they have so here's all this wisdom
about and and I listen to their wisdom
and I think yeah that's wisdom this is
this is stuff that you can hear Jordan
Peterson tell you that you can get from
Marcus Aurelius they can get from all of
these people but but where stoicism
finally sort of bottoms out is that yeah
if you have a kid and if you love that
kid don't forget that proviso because I
get I think part of the part of the V
hangover and post Christendom is that
Christianity shamed us into a certain
level of love that society continues to
maintain that yet to abandon your kids
you're still a schmuck and we all know
that so so suddenly the having of that
child and parenting of that child begins
to have a sacramental effect because and
and one of the first people I talked to
after I made my first video was someone
who lives near ER and I had lunch with
him and he said you know this was a guy
who was studying for the ministry and
then he got to a point in reading all of
the Protestant theology and he said I
don't believe any of it and then he
listened to Sam Harris and he went
through the whole thing with okay and
then he met a woman had a kid and began
to realize in himself
I'm and I've talked to a lot of people
like this what if something happens to
my kid I love my kid that kid isn't just
a bunch of atoms and and and something
in the real
a ship with my child suggests that it's
not merely a psychological trick or an
evolutionary product that I am bounded
to this child but there's something in
this moment that connects heaven and
earth and I am deeply disturbed by that
realization and it's not going to leave
me alone until I get an answer that is
satisfying and so here's so I listen to
Eric talked to Ryan holiday about what
these people need to do is have kids and
I think yeah I've got five of them um
they're that they're you know it's sort
of like the like stories of old you keep
using those tools yeah it's some going
you know the tool that at some point the
stones start talking to you yeah oh yeah
that's it that's a great that's a great
way to put it and there's a reason why
stoicism failed like it failed in the
sense that it failed to make
civilization it it's a it's like it has
use used to it but stoicism only really
succeeded when it was bound within
Christianity because a lot of people
will tell you that Christianity is a is
actually a large largely of akin to
stoicism that's the better right a kid
there yeah there it's a kid too stoicism
there are aspects of so sysm within
Christianity but stoicism doesn't offer
you doesn't offer you a tour II to live
in it doesn't offer you a story to exist
in and the same thing within your plate
inist like the neoplatonist just
couldn't they just couldn't break
through because because it was a theory
and it was a bunch of you know this it
was a theory about the about reality but
it wasn't an enacted story wasn't an
enacted something that you entered into
and it didn't create the type of
communion that would bind people
together and so you have Marcus Aurelius
being a stoic you know on his own and
whining that everybody is you know and
and and and complaining that everybody's
is a degenerate but like we wouldn't say
it that way but you know like just being
this like you know taking the world on
his shoulders and doing his thing you
know taking it all on himself but it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't come
together which which is exactly I've
watched enough Christians deconstruct
which is what I find exactly what
happens to people who deconstruct from
Christianity so they sort of become
Stoics and they they take the world on
their shoulders and they're really
frustrated with everyone who's who's not
pulling their share and not doing you
know not not carrying the load with them
and it's like and and so then I get to
agustin and so yeah Manichaean ISM and
when you people always use Manichaean as
a as kind of an exact kind of an
illustration of dualism go would look
what the mannequins believe it's wild
stuff and and then and then of course
neoplatonism but I think you said it's
work so Wow here's this incredibly
brilliant fought through neoplatonist
image of the world but if you read
confessions talk about a book dripping
with pathos right and relation and you
know so so John John very key and I just
had just at a conversation last week and
I think the conversation went very well
and so we're where John and I sort of
you know come up against each other is
exactly this this question of personhood
and in your conversation with John which
which was was quite esoteric but I
thought I really enjoyed it and and I
thought you nailed it right on the head
when you said you know it's person
person person you get past a certain
point it's gonna be person up and person
down you know if you want to say it's
it's impersonal beyond this point well
you can say that but you can't know it
anyway because you're just a human being
and you know in you know in my
conversation I just finished with with
Brett shackled
I'm gonna post yours tomorrow or Brett's
tomorrow but um you know we I think I
think the thing that we finally come
down to it we never see really get past
Genesis 3 that in a sense the Genesis 3
story is about a conspiracy theory in
all that the snake does is say you know
just makes a few suggestions and frame
it in a certain way and can we finally
trust our maker can we finally trust it
can we as tiny little scared creatures
finally surrender our hearts and say
this is what I am this is and and and
and I no matter how much money and power
and technology and all the stuff that
this world has to offer for Jesus and
all this debt this is this is what I am
and what my heart desires is to is to
love and be loved and you know
Neoplatonism Agustin didn't end there
for a reason and I so I watched the
Stoics and I think I'd rather have my
neighbor be a stoic than a hedonist yeah
I'd still rather they be a good
Christian who gives lay down lays down
their life for their neighbor all the
way up to and including their enemy yeah
no I I agree and I think that like I
think that it just that's one of the
reasons why it happened the way did that
one of the reasons why Neoplatonism and
crit and stoicism were taken into
christianity because it offered that it
offered the story it offered the the
pathos and it offered the personalism
like if you want to say it that way it
offered the fact that the world actually
manifests itself through personal
categories you could say it that way
which is that
and and and it really is the idea you
could say of intelligences you know
that's how we talk about so we talked
about principalities and angels that the
world actually manifests itself through
intelligences it's not concepts like the
way that that the kind of let's say the
kind of basic platonic way of
understanding it that there are these
like form that are something like
concepts that are kind of like these but
no they're intelligences they're the
world manifests itself by through
intelligences and once you kind of get
that then all of a sudden you realize
well there's a reason why because the
stoic a stoic doesn't have to worship
and they don't worship but it also means
if you don't celebrate then you don't
come together it's just not it's just
very simple the world is a celebration
is the beginning of reality it's the way
that reality it's the it's the relevance
realization worship is relevance
realization oh that's what worship is it
is it is it is celebrating the
disclosure of of of the source of how
things come together and are one and
exists in love like you could say it
that way and so I think that that's why
that's why worship even that and that's
one of the things in my conversation
with John that I was trying to kind of
pull out of him which you know maybe is
a bit is a bit is a bit tricky on my
part but I was trying to pull out of him
that even even non theistic religions
like certain strands of Buddhism or
Taoism that if they posit the highest in
terms of non-being it still manifest
itself as beings all the way down and so
it's like okay so you say that ultimate
reality in in terms of Buddhism is a
form of annihilation okay but then there
are all these bodhisattva's like that
start right at the door of annihilation
all the way down to hell you have this
like
Araki of beings that come down and it's
the same in Taoism and it's the same in
Hinduism and it's the same in every
religion understands the world as a
hierarchy of beings and the hierarchy of
intelligences and not and and that means
that it has to do with celebration and
love and devotion also it's not just
that it's not only that but it's also
part of it right it's not just story but
you can't get rid of story it's not just
devotion but you can't get rid of
devotion and I think you know I think
folk religion you know one of the things
that always interested me about when I
first started watching friends and
neighbors you know start getting all
excited about American style Buddhism
was I thought no wait a minute
you know you go you go you go over there
and you take a look at those Buddhists
and I remember when there was a jetliner
that was broken down on a runway and the
Buddhist monks came out and sacrificed a
goat to get that you know sucker moving
again and I thought oh wait a minute
wait a minute oh my oh my Western
secular friends are going to these
places and meditating and do all that
because this religiosity that's you know
that's all the problematic stuff but
those are Buddhists sacrificing and go
on an airstrip yes why is that happening
well I always say that my Catholic
grandmother was more buddhas than all
these California Judas for sure well and
that gets into the idea folk religion
where we're you know so so JD Vance's
meemaw was you know a Protestant folk
religionist in many ways but but there's
a there's a you know even though she
didn't go to church there was there was
at least still a haunting of an
inclination of what you just described
that she was that she was not going to
in some ways the entire artifice of what
we've seen as new atheism
is so fragile because it can it can sort
of only be maintained as a grudge I'm
serious about that no you're right
you're totally right
it can only be maintained as I'm I'm not
going to worship yeah and all your
videos are debunking yeah yeah okay
let's see it's kind of like dealing with
a two-year-old it says you know I'm not
gonna eat anymore all right
hey go for it I'll talk to you tomorrow
I'll take your dinner away yeah yo P
baby but do you see that yeah you see
that in the end you end up having the
Atheist today they have to end up saying
things like was a the Dawkins who said
I'm a culturally Christian atheist and
then jejak who says he's a Christian
atheist and you're gonna end up having
that error or who's the other guy the
the crowds guy I'm horrible with names
the the problem with the one who wrote
the strange death of Europe what's his
name Oh Douglas yeah so Douglas Murray
he's the same as he is like I'm a
Christian atheist you're gonna get
you're gonna get a lot more of that but
then it also but then it and it
hopefully it plays itself out right
because there's at some point when you
say at some point when you say it's like
there's this real reality okay great
mean that has appeared online I think it
was like Mike Serna [ __ ] you posted it
that I saw at least and it was you know
that exploding mind meme where it's it's
like the mind keeps getting bigger and
more bright and then it's like you keep
getting more and more intelligent or
whatever um and it and it was it was
basically about God and it the first one
was I believe in God it's like a little
brain and then it says I don't believe
in God and like a bigger brain then he
says I believe that God is a useful
construct you know for keeping societies
together and is a bigger brain and then
the other one is that without God
society breaks down and everything like
Falls to hell and then the last ones
like well I believe in God because like
what what do you mean it's up so that's
not real
like that's not real that if you don't
have God or you don't have some religion
then everything falls apart that's not a
real thing that's a real thing that's a
real thing in the world and it actually
happens just like symbolism now so
that's what I've been I just I just keep
I just keep I just keep it at some yeah
yeah yeah cuz I can't get enough of it
and and people like you and and others
indulge my indulge my itch by making me
no longer be able to watch Donkey Kong
with any kind of the innocence I had
before yeah well I have a people I have
a lot like just today I was talking with
some people that my kind of top patrons
and and one of the guys Kyle I think he
was on your your your channel and so he
I think he watches you and he was he was
talking about and he was actually giving
me a frame that I might want to bring up
with you right now because he was
because one of the problems that I've
been trying to understand in terms of
symbolism it's just hard because we're
in it right now is to understand the
flip that happened during the pandemic
cuz it's a it's very odd right it's very
odd you had you had a moment in March
mmm where all the left-leaning all the
liberal types we're saying it's evil to
shut the border it's racist xenophobic
it's all this bla bla bla bla bla and
the people who were conservatives were
saying no this is a serious pandemic we
got to shut it down and then it flipped
completely upside down like the whole
thing the whole discourse complete
changed and then all of a sudden it was
the people who were were on the Left
were saying we need to shut down forever
two years like it's gonna this is never
gonna come back it's never gonna change
and then the others are saying you free
I need to be free like like you can't
shut us down this is government tyranny
valo
and I thought wow it's in it's crazy how
how it totally flipped and then he said
that you were talking about the
strength and compassion right yeah so
the Republicans the Republicans you know
exactly what's gonna happen
watch the 2016 Republican candidates
debate each other about who should be at
the head of the party and then look at
the twenty twenty Democrats that big
field debate each other the the
Republicans the Republicans always sort
of manifest strength hmm we are about
strength and so Donald Trump you know
wants to manifest strength and the
Democrats kindness compassion and so you
know Republicans we're going to fund you
we can't put enough money towards
national security we can't we can't
spend enough money on keeping ourselves
safe even though the United States
spends more than the next six countries
combined the Democrats we can't spend
enough money throwing it at suffering
people because if they're suffering you
know we're sure that that some amount of
money will fix it mm-hm and I think part
of what happens in a pandemic is that
both get exposed hmm and and so you know
the shutdown well you know for a while I
mean when Trump was running for office
you know one of the things he was gonna
end is the national deficit because
there's gonna be so much money coming in
and yeah yeah yeah and and so now of
course then the Dems are all worried
about the deficit and now you know well
we just you know four trillion dollars
in one fell swoop and now the Dems are
back and wanting to do another three
trillion and and so everything's all
inverted you're exactly right because
well well what what are you afraid of
and you know in in a sense at least the
the Republicans are afraid of their
loss of Liberty and the Dems are afraid
of losing their life because you know
it's it's been very interesting again
this gets it this gets into so in in
1960 John Fitzgerald Kennedy the
Democratic Senate senator from
Massachusetts ran for president of the
United States and the dominant concern
was can we elect a Roman Catholic right
in 2004 another JFK John Kerry the
democratic senator from Massachusetts
who was also a celebrated war veteran
ran for president on the Democratic
ticket and most Catholics didn't vote
for him in 2020 we're going to have a
Friesian so that's my mother side
Friesians they're Germans and Dutch
we're going to have a Frisian who his
most abiding church connection was the
Reformed Church in America so Donald
Trump religiously is my cousin okay yeah
region yeah oh gosh Reformed the
enormous vincent peale prosperity gospel
hmm running against Joe Biden who of
course is a Roman Catholic and Joe Biden
goes to church more than Donald Trump
okay
now all of these church labels what on
earth do they mean I mean anything
anymore yeah and well here's the
question and so then Tom Hollands work
comes through his book Dominion which is
a very interesting book he basically
comes through and says which really
annoys the secularists you know how
deeply Christian our entire society is
you know we can't
Christianity runs through everything
that we're doing all of our fights are
in a sense within Christianity oh yeah
that's an equal opportunity
because the secularists you know say no
it's the Enlightenment in' and somehow
our culture is a clean room artifact of
the Greeks and Tom Holland says hey I've
spent my life writing stuff about the
Greeks we're nothing like the Greeks oh
yeah my goodness no and and on the other
side the Christians are saying no we've
you know Christian people are this is
how you define Christian people by their
religiosity and it's like well you know
there's there's a lot of stuff about
religiosity that it isn't merely
religiosity either and so we have
inversions all over the place right now
no you're right and and it's but but I
thought the topsy-turvy like that I
guess that's the the problem of the
topsy-turvy world is things just keep
flipping and you don't know and it's
like juggling it's you know you don't
know what's going on I think some things
are out things are down and so it's
it'll be interesting to see how it's
going to to play out but there was still
like it was interesting the way that he
had framed it based on your categories I
thought it was a good idea he said when
at the beginning that the Republicans
were acting out of strength by saying
we're gonna shut our borders right right
and the Democrats were acting out of
compassion by saying no no we need to
let people in yeah and then when it
flipped their ciliate we're using the
same the same the same reason like so
that the person the Republican is saying
you know oh no I'm gonna be strength I
can't let someone control me I need to
go outside and not wear a mask and do
that and the other is saying no you need
to protect others and save lives and
isolate yourself to save lives and so it
ends up being the same motivation which
is creating the opposite the opposite
reaction yep and so it's fascinating to
watch it it's really fascinating to
watch it and it'll you know it's crazy
when we said it'll have like you know
what what do you think you know and I
think in some ways you know because I
think I think a fair amount about I mean
the the the rising of the or
knocks Church with envy within the
church landscape in America is
fascinating to me and you know
especially in the light of this because
I think about Rod Dreher how you know
rod drear goes to his priest and says
you know we want to we want to practice
you know Roman Catholic family planning
and his priest rolls his eyes and says
oh you're one of those and you know
within not too long Roger ear will be
Orthodox so you know so in a sense what
we've seen is that we used to have these
labels like Roman Catholic John Kennedy
is Roman Catholic and that label stood
for something there was a witness there
that by the time of John Kerry the
witness is completely do you know
diluted yeah and now the awards were I
think rod rares analysis of this
situation is the best I think that I
mean his vision is that to a certain
extent they're right now what's really
happening is that there are Christians
who take it seriously and they're
Christians who don't who base their
motivation on their faith and there are
Christians who base their motivation on
other factors that they base it on other
factors and those Christians that base
their motivation on their faith they end
up seeing each other across
denominations and so it's like I feel
more akin and a lot of worth attacks
might be annoyed that I'll say that but
I feel way more akin even with
evangelical who who wants to get rid of
the sins in his life and wants to be
faithful to his wife and wants to to
worship God the way he thinks it's he's
capable of doing who wants his culture
to be coherent
I feel more akin to that person and I do
too some Greek Orthodox nominal Orthodox
who goes to church three times a year
and you know it's like guy I yeah so I
can see you across the the across the
lane and I'm like why you know it we
disagree on things but I
I can see you and the other person is
just like me but we're getting so now
work and relevance realization because
we're trying to figure out what it is
what's the pattern like what what is the
thing that's making this this is
disappear as a pattern right because
we're the first things people who are
these who are these yeah who are these
American conservative Rod Dreher tides
like we're how is it that they're in the
weird communion but they don't go to
church together they wouldn't take the
chalice together there but they still
feel a sense of weird and a lot of a lot
of these types of people are Nanak you
mental is actually like we we don't
believe in a humanism but we actually
see each other across the lines and say
one of the reasons why I feel like into
you is because you take your difference
with me seriously right and you're
willing to we'd actually have to like
talk it out and take it seriously
instead of saying it doesn't matter it's
all good like whatever let's all have a
big a big party and just forget about
our differences as if that does anything
and I think some of that so Chuck you
know who Chuck Colson is he was one of
Richard Nixon's hatchet men he wrote
this book born-again yeah I've heard of
that book yeah so so when born again you
know Chuck Colson comes to his wife and
says I'm a Christian and his wife looks
at him is like you're Episcopalian you
know no no now really so and and I think
in a lot of ways what we've been working
on for the last 60 years now in an
ecumenical frame is what is what is it
what is what is what is that thing what
is that thing that that binds an Eastern
Orthodox icon carver with a Dutch
Reformed from an iconoclastic background
because of course they smashed half the
monasteries and defect you know laughing
and and I and my like denomination is
you know conservative enough that there
are some quarters where van der clay is
talking to an icon Carver doesn't
doesn't Jonathan POJO make idols and OH
conversation so but that's part of
exactly what we're in right now and it's
manifest in the strange the strange
ecumenism that is happening at this
level because a lot of what's been
passed off as ecumenical conversations
we look at and say I'm not really
interested in that because it's it's
just it's like a weird fluffy pretend
it's like you're pretending yeah yeah I
think there's an honesty about maybe at
this level that we're trying to identify
there's an honesty right there's an
honesty about actual differences in
actual resemblances instead of just
trying to to to cast it all aside I
remember having a discussion when I was
here it was really I was young I was in
Orthodox like I was evangelical and I
remember meeting a Catholic um guy and
he was like Oh Christians we just all
need to come together we just all need
to be together and together and and I
was like well I said I know some
Christians who think that when you pray
to Mary you're praying did the devil and
so what do you do with that and you said
oh well they just have to put that aside
well I'm like well I don't know what to
tell you because that doesn't work that
way like you you can't just throw
everything out that's debts deal with it
let's talk about it we might disagree
but if you just say let's pretend like
it's not there you know it's like Pat it
ends up you know it'll look really nice
for a little while and then it'll be all
passive-aggressive from then on well and
to me this gets back to one of the
earlier things that I saw in Jordan
where he says you know first you act it
out and I think that gets into worship
what we talked about and sacramentality
because okay let's all be together so so
let's go let's go worship at your house
today and you come in and oh there's the
statue and Jesus is up on the cross and
all you know start to get a little bit
of nervous and you know people are
dipping in the holy water and and at
what point will something inside of me
say
okay there's the line I can't cross that
line yet exactly and and but but at
least there is a line yes yeah because
in a sense what we what we sort of what
began wandering into you know because
this inversion seems very much to have
something kicked off in the 60s that got
us going in here there so so where
exactly is the line and what is the line
and what is that what is that line
really connected to and harfa how far up
and down does that line there we go and
will you actually live by that line hmm
not at all so arbitrary it has to do it
I think a lot of it has to do with
honesty I think that I think a lot of it
had to do with honesty and that's what
makes like I said just that's what makes
us able to see each other across the
line is that you're not pretending you
know that this is like you for example
like if I brought you to an Orthodox
Church you wouldn't pretend that it's
all fine you'd be like okay that's this
is my line and so we can actually talk
about it you know like I went to I went
to this year I went to like a Christmas
service one of the Christmas services in
a major kind of Pentecostal type
evangelical church and it was and it was
more like a big play but he was still in
the church and and and it was like the
whole time was like I'm gonna you know
and then it was like it's it's kept
happening and then when the acrobats
came out I was like that's it
this is my line like this is the line
where I'm like nope nope when I've got
the girls like dropping from like the
cloth ins in leotards in the church I'm
like that's it like I just that I just
can't I just can't
I'm not here anymore I'm just not here
anymore so I could imagine like you said
but then if I if I saw the pastor of
that church was a very who someone has
extreme integrity and is extremely
impressive in terms of his life and
terms of his devotion you know I can
still see him across the line but I'm
not gonna pretend like it's fine that
that I think it's fine he has acrobats
in his church I'm not
[Laughter]
well and and to me as you know so so
when I listen to people talk about me
and other things they'll say well he's
this he's this pastor who's high in
openness and it's like I'm not sure
that's always a good thing
but I've always I've always as a
Protestant wondered so why is it okay to
bring the donkey into the building and
have the Christmas pageant but it's
idolatry to have a picture of a donkey
in stained glass you know and and so oh
you're so right you're so right but I I
really like I yeah I I really do think
that one of the reasons if you are
honest about what you believe and you're
honest about what your limits are and
you don't pretend and you know what it
is then I think that that permits a lot
of openness and he permits it from its
indefinite openness because you're open
to a certain level you know like I
couldn't have a discussion I think like
I could have a discussion with anybody
yeah but I doesn't mean that I have to
concede the things that are important to
me just because I'm having the
discussion you know uh
and so so I think that that's it like if
you're honest and and you know what you
believe and you know what you are then
you actually have a lot of room to talk
to other people yeah yeah no I and again
people sometimes ask me because they're
surprised that I'm a pastor and I'm like
this and I think that's surprising but
you know I learned so much of this from
my father because I learned from him
exactly what you just said if you know
who you are and you know what you
believe then the other person's whatever
it is they are and are saying and doing
it doesn't really threaten you hmm
because that's them and you're you and
you actually know the difference between
them and you a lot of people don't what
did you know and but it ends up
manifesting itself in all kinds of ways
where for example you know let's say
people who just
to accept tradition from other cultures
it's like you're deluding yourself you
it'd be way better for you to say well
you know what like that like the
sacrificing of the goats no I don't want
that like I don't I don't want that I
don't think that's okay I want a
mechanic not I'm not a goat sacrifice
that until once you at least say no that
I think is then you can have an actual
discussion but if you pretend like it's
all okay like you have no idea how weird
other people's other people's way of
doing things is right you have no idea
like there are cultures where people
still beat their wives and so you would
have to at some point saying well they
don't know that no I don't that's that's
not acceptable
right and so it's better to just know
and then then but then I could talk to a
guy who beats his wife like I could have
a discussion with him you know and I but
I wouldn't agree with his behavior but I
can talk with the murderer I could talk
with the with that with with with people
who live in a way that I disagree with
you know I don't feel like I need to to
pure it to keep myself pure from
anything that's not like me yeah yeah
well yeah yeah no I agree I agree well
we've done that we've done almost two
hours two hours you you really pull me
like two because I usually I never have
like to our conversation so he's like
after an hour I start being like okay
you know we've gone through everything
but would you got me going for two hours
it's awesome and laughing the whole time
Joe Joe Rogan watch yourself baby well
Jonathan so we should give you it not
that not that my you can of course post
this on your blog to us and on your
channel to us send you the file but you
know you've got your blog going and it's
that is that on your regular domain you
can get there from your regular say the
symbolic on the now it's gonna be my
things are gonna start to focus on my
website so this symbolic WorldCom I'm
gonna start to have more things there
you know articles and also if I appear
on other channels and so I'm gonna start
to consolidate
that in that and on that website so it's
gonna become the place
you still think they're gonna they're
gonna clamp down and take YouTube away
from us um I think they're good I think
they're going to do it very slowly and I
think it's already happened I think it's
already happening I've seen it happen I
saw I did you know it's like obviously
they can probably their algorithm could
probably identity identifying with join
Peterson they identify me with more
conservatives and I saw like I did a
video I it was called is Christianity a
cuckold religion right and the video was
really trying to explain a pattern um
but I think the fact that I used that
word and I'm already kind of associated
probably with more right-leaning stuff
and everything I saw it happened in real
time the video took off in like I had
like 20,000 views in one day and then it
stopped and they just went flat and I
thought oh okay what's going on and then
from then on I've seen my views like
kind of hold at a certain amount of
views and I part of it is the fact that
during Peterson's gone that's for sure
but part of it is also I think you know
I don't think it's a human decision I
think it's just their algorithm just
starts just marginalizes people who who
are not in line with what they want so I
think it's already happening and it's
better for them if I was if their
strategic it's better for them to keep
you on their platform but make you as
marginal as possible because that way
you're not putting the effort into
finding other platforms you know yeah
yeah that's what I think is going on
there there really isn't a because there
really isn't a platform competitor nope
like YouTube there really isn't like I
upload all my stuff on [ __ ] you but
[ __ ] you [ __ ] shoot is crap it's a
just not well done it's not well
programmed the search is not good you
know there's no recommendation the way
that YouTube recommends video so it's
hard to get more reach outside of your
reach and so you there is no competitor
so I don't know I don't really know yeah
and think spot is just not it's just not
panning out it's just say you know I
respect what they're doing and I and I
respect the fact that they're putting in
all this effort but if you go on there
yeah you know even the most famous
person has very few reactions yeah oh
well well we'll just got along well yeah
grace of God that's right it's that's
that's being a Christian helps me not
worry too much about these things cuz
there you go as here we are in right now
but thank you Jonathan thank you for
your time and and most of all again
thank you for the work that you do
because I I think it's really important
and I think it's excellent work and you
really do help me see the world in a
different way you inform my Bible
reading you inform my culture watching
and you've just opened up whole new
vistas for me that apart from you I
don't know that I'd see so thank you
well thanks and thanks for all the
insane work you put into these
discussions and I hope that we will meet
in person we were supposed to and now it
might not happen but I let's hope that
we get to meet Lord willing one way or
another I believe it will happen and I
look forward to that day all right all
right bye Paul Thank You Jonathan
bye-bye